I think uh one of the things that we've
done that led to the success of our
operation Far and Away the one thing I
did for the success of this operation
one of the most important things we've
done to make our operation succeed is
this has to be the success to our
operation hi I'm buz Clute scientist and
I want to let you in on a little secret
the best education that I've received in
the last 15 years has been from
producers like you today's topic is
about the secret to successful
operations we've been talking to
Progressive farmers and ranchers across
South Dakota and here's what Rancher AJ
hes has to say the one thing I have done
to the success of this operation that I
would say benefited the most would
definitely be the rotational system it
absolutely helped with the grass it made
the soil better it it made us run 40%
more cattle it cheapened up our daily
cost of grazing the producer has spoken
and the professor has been schooled